You know that old saying, "Put your money
where your mouth is?"
Turns out - not such a great idea!
I was just as surprised as you.
Hey guys Tara here for Dnews - and it turns
out, everything is disgusting.
You may have seen Anthony's video a while
back talking about all the gross, weird things
that were discovered on British bank notes
- but it turns out American dollars may be
even worse.
A team of researchers at NYU have conducted
the first comprehensive DNA study on $1 bills
in Manhattan, and found 3,000 different types
of bacteria - which is way more than any previous
study.
By far the most common bacteria they discovered,
is one known to cause acne.
And if that's not enough to convince you to
wash your hands after touching money, then
wait til you hear this.
In addition to both mouth and vaginal microbes,
researchers also found genes linked to staph
infections, pneumonia, gastric ulcers, food
poisoning, and antibiotic resistance.
They even found trace amounts of anthrax,
which is a common bacteria found in soil - but
isn't harmful enough to cause a reaction in
doses this small.
Still creepy.
And even creepier than that - less than half
the DNA they found was actually human.
They discovered everything from horse DNA,
to dog DNA - even a snippet of white rhino
DNA.
Because that makes total makes sense in Manhattan.
Of course there's white rhino DNA.
Why wouldn't there be?
Seriously though, most of this we shouldn't
be too surprised to hear.
After all, money is one of the most frequently
exchanged items in the world.
But American money is especially prone to
bacteria, because it's printed on cotton-based
paper - which is way absorbent than the plastic
polymer notes that countries like India and
Canada use.
It also makes our money less durable.
The average lifetime of a $1 bill, is only
21 months.
And because of that, the Federal Reserve spends
almost a billion dollars every year just on
printing new money.
What do you guys think of this?
Should America switch to a polymer-based currency?
Imagine how great our skin would look!
It'll be like those awkward teenage years
never even happened.
Leave your thoughts in the comments below,
and hey - if you like reading, then why not
take a second to check out Audible?
Audible.com is the leading provider of downloadable
digital audiobooks - which means yes, they
are 100% germ-free.
Choose from over 100,000 titles in every genre
imaginable - then just download them to your
ipod or mp3 player and play them back anytime,
anywhere.
Even better, when you sign up at audiblepodcast.com/dnews
- we will hook you up with a free audiobook
download of your choice.
And if you're looking for something new to
dive into, I highly recommend The Sirens of
Titan - one of my favorite books of all time,
I promise you won't be disappointed.
Again the link for your free audiobook is
audiblepodcast.com/dnews, and as always - if
you wanna see more episodes of Dnews, then
be sure to subscribe here.